دكتور فوشي لدينا مقطع فيديو لنائب
الرئيس بنس والسيدة الثانية التي يتم
تطعيمها هذا الصباح
جنبًا إلى جنب مع الجراح العام ،
نعلم أن الرئيس المنتخب بايدن
يخطط للحصول على جرعته الأولى على ما أعتقد يوم الاثنين
جزئيًا لأسباب تتعلق بالأمن القومي
السؤال الذي أعنيه هل يجب
أن يتم تطعيم الرئيس ترامب أنا
أعلم أنه مصاب بالعدوى
ولكن ما الذي
ستوصي به في هذه الحالة
حسنًا هذا اختيار شخصي أه سانجاي
بين الرئيس وأطبائه
أحد الأشياء
التي  عليك أن تضع في اعتبارك أنه
تلقى الجسم المضاد أحادي النسيلة عندما
كان مريضًا ،
لذلك ربما لا يزال لديه مستوى عالٍ جدًا
من أي شخص في نظامه قد
ترغب في الانتظار قليلاً قبل أن تقوم
بتطعيمه فعليًا لذلك لا أعرف بالضبط
سبب عدم وجوده ولكني أعتقد أن هذا
قد يكون أحد الأسباب
ولكن في النهاية قد يرغب في الحصول على
اللقاح ، لقد أوصيت
علنًا بأن يكون هو ونائب الرئيس
بنس  في النهاية تم التطعيم
وكما تعلم ،
تم تطعيم نائب الرئيس اليوم علنًا وهو أمر
جيد حقًا ، فأنا أحب هذا المثال
ليس فقط لنائب الرئيس ولكن أيضًا
للجراح العام آدمز للقيام
بذلك وأعتقد أن هذا كان شيئًا جيدًا
يمثل للمجتمع أمام
الأشخاص الذين يشاهدون
أن هذا شيء يجب علينا جميعًا
القيام به لأننا نقوم بتطعيم غالبية
الناس في هذا البلد ،
سنقوم بتغيير
هذا الأمر بالتأكيد